hi everybody as you can tell I'm am
American I've never given a
but my friends have assured me that if
I'm doing very bad that you'll all be
very polite and not say anything and
that if I'm doing very well you'll do
the same thing so I'll take your silence
as approval
she said I'm a head of data science at
code Academy before that I was actually
writing the data science data analytics
curriculum at code Academy but before
that I was a scientist working in
computational biochemistry and coming
from a hard science background to a more
computational data science background
I've been a little bit disappointed and
so that's why I wanted to give this talk
so that we can all learn together about
best practices for hypothesis testing so
first I want to just give a brief
overview about why we would even want to
learn hypothesis testing so classic
example from my previous line of work if
we're testing a new drug and we want to
know you know say it raises good
cholesterol we want to know if the new
drug is better we see a difference but
how do we know that that's a real
difference now in my current job I work
a lot with product data so for instance
subscriptions if we see a drop in the
number of subscriptions how do we know
if that's a real difference or just
statistical points and the reason that
this is a problem is really not every
difference is significant so this was
just a chart I made in C born using
numpy and as you can see all three bars
were generated from distributions with
the same mean and standard deviation but
they still can look quite different so
this is why we need to test so one of
the big misconceptions that I see a lot
is people don't know or they misuse the
term significant what does it mean to be
significant so the definition and we're
going to go into this a lot more because
this doesn't necessarily mean that
anything to people is that the
difference we've observed probably isn't
due to chance we'll get into that
probability part of it a little later
but where I really see a lot of
misunderstandings is when we talk about
not significant a lot of times I'll be
working with a product manager who's
running an a beet
and he'll come to me it's always a him
he'll come to me and say you know I've
been running the experiment for the
sample size that you told me I needed to
run it for and it's not significant yet
so let's run it for another two weeks
and that's very bad you shouldn't do
that
not significant is fine non significant
means that your variant the experiment
you're running just isn't as good as you
think it is and there is no difference
with the control group as long as you've
run your experiment for long enough it's
fine for it to be significant it doesn't
mean you did something wrong but in fact
this is almost always an interview
question that we use so if anybody's
interviewing for data analysis for Rawls
hopefully you'll be asked this so I
wanted to take a moment and just ask all
of you why did you come here today what
is it that you want to learn to
hypothesis tasks so does anyone want to
share a scenario I'm not seeing hands
okay
excellent mm-hmm students t-test will
definitely be going over that anyone
else have an example of when they'd like
think they might like to use hypothesis
testing or did you all just run in here
sort of randomly we don't have food so I
know you're not here for the food
okay so I'll talk about a few different
examples obviously you know drug
development was where I used a lot of
hypothesis testing a B testing does
everyone know what a B testing means
when we say that okay so I'm just gonna
just in case a B testing is when we have
two versions of something maybe we've
made two different versions of our
landing page and we want to see which of
those versions leads to more people
signing up other examples I used to work
at an education technology company where
we made adaptive learning smart
textbooks and we wanted to see if those
textbooks were actually making students
smarter so we had to do a randomized
controlled trial we gave half the people
a regular textbook half the people a
smart textbook and then gave them a test
at the end and a big question that we
always had is you know how big of a
class do we need can we run this in one
single class of 30 students or do we
need to run it across an entire school
with hundreds of students
okay so hypothesis testing so as you
pointed out it can be very difficult to
know which hypothesis test to use so
first of all let's go over really
quickly what it is a hypothesis test is
a way of reframing our qualitative
question is this difference real into
something much more mathematical we're
trying to figure out what is the
probability that the difference is due
to chance versus not and so we're trying
to do if anyone remembers back in you
know college math when you learned about
proof by contradiction we're trying to
do a proof by contradiction we start by
assuming the null hypothesis which is
the
is no difference and that what we're
seeing is just random and then we pick
one of these tests and the goal of all
of the tests is to generate a p-value
and the p-value is the probability of
the null hypothesis and generally it
varies a lot by what you're trying to do
but generally we want the p-value to be
less than 0.05 and that's how we know
that we're doing things correctly anyone
have any questions cool okay so how do
we pick which hypothesis test this is I
think the reason why everyone is
actually here so this is going to be a
very broad overview I you know I
wouldn't take this to a statistics
midterm but I think this is quite good
for anyone who's working in industry and
running different types of tests so the
first question you always ask is is my
data categorical or numerical so
numerical data is something like revenue
it's something where there's actually a
bunch of numbers and you tend to have a
lot of samples so for instance you know
how much money you made every single
month and those are gonna be your
samples or you have you know the heights
of all the students in the class and you
want to compare those categorical data
which actually find I work with more
frequently tends to be things that look
like percentages so the categories are
did I buy the product or didn't I did I
click a link or didn't I and it can be
really confusing a lot of people will
sort of try to use a t-test on that
categorical data they'll be like oh but
you know how does that work because all
I have is one number I have the
percentage 75% of people purchased my
product 20% of people opened an email so
that's important the next question is
how many samples am i comparing and buy
samples I mean not like the individual
samples but like how many groups am i
comparing so there are tests for one
sample versus some theoretical number so
this works either really well for if you
have some sort of target like if you say
my you know in my okay our planning they
said that I have to get you know
at least 30% of people clicking this
link
you're comparing whatever number you
actually got to that theoretical 30%
there aren't multiple 30% there's just
one it can also work well if there's a
no number in the literature that you're
comparing against so maybe if people say
well the average height of an American
woman is five foot four so I'm gonna
compare the height of heights of
everyone who I measured to that five
foot four and see if they're different
two sample means you have two samples
it's probably the most common thing and
then sometimes we'll have more than two
samples sometimes you know we'll have
three variants of an a/b test or we'll
have three different populations that we
want to compare and it turns out we'll
actually need a different test for that
so this is probably the most important
slide of this talk this is just a table
that helps you know which of your tests
you want to use I'm not going to read
through the entire thing because I think
that would be boring but if you're if
you're taking notes or if you're taking
pictures this is probably the important
one to take down okay
so people who were here early and heard
me say this we're going to practice now
and we're gonna practice using code
Academy I promise I am NOT just showing
for code Academy I really did try to
think of a way to do this talk without
using it but I realized I would have had
to make like a big Dropbox link and we
would have all had to download things
and load them into Jupiter notebooks and
it would have been a mess so we're gonna
let code Academy do the hard work for us
so if everyone could just take a moment
and follow that link to this course that
would be lovely
if you want to type in the whole long
link you can otherwise you can type in
the short link and if I do this properly
I'm gonna be switching back and forth
between the slides and the link I am
still there
yeah that's big enough to see pardon oh
go back to the site sure I have a little
timer up here so I'm gonna give you guys
30 seconds to follow the link does that
sound fair huh pardon sure why not
how do you guys want me to make them
available it's like okay I will I will
have to join a slash channel and then I
will make them available but I promise I
will okay cool
all right your 30 seconds are almost up
all right let's get started okay so this
is a fun little d3 thing that we made to
sort of prove to you that hypothesis
testing is important you can change the
means and the standard deviations of the
number of samples and see the p-value
and if it's significantly different and
that's all a lot of fun but I think
that's not what you came here for so we
can all click Next okay so the first
test and now I'm gonna this is where
it's gonna get interesting and we're
going to be switching back and forth
okay so okay so the first thing that
we're going to do is a one sample t-test
so T tests remember if you remember our
grid R for numerical data and this is
when we're comparing against some sort
of an ideal so we we use this when we're
either comparing two targets or
comparing to a known value the function
that we're gonna use we do from scipy
dot stats import t-test one the samp and
the arguments it takes are a vector with
our observations and then the actual
expected mean that we want to
you get from it it's going to return two
things a t statistic and a p-value you
don't care about the T statistic you
only care about the p-value that's the
thing that you want to be less than 0.05
okay so you can all see that there's a
whole story if you want to read but what
might be better oh I have to reset this
there we go okay cool so for those of
you who here has used code Academy
before okay a lot of you but not all of
you so the way code Academy basically
works is we type into the center if this
is our code editor it's set up to be a
little bit like vim or Emacs and then we
click run when we think we have the
answer to the question and if we do it
right this little guy will turn green
and sometimes will even see things show
up in this part of the screen sound fair
okay so let's all take a moment and work
through question one together so this
fun it's like being back in school
anyways so we ought we have a small data
set called ages we can even print it to
take a look at it and I think that was
actually the first thing you were
supposed to do anyway so that's good
okay so what do we think about the size
of this data set overall do we think
this is representative is this like a
good size to be working with probably
not right this is more of a toy example
generally when we're running t-test
we're hoping to have a lot more but it's
not completely crazy to have a data set
like this so for instance a lot of times
if you're looking at something like
revenue over time your company might be
working at a start-up you might only
have 12 months of data so you might be
working with a size like this it just
means that you're gonna have a harder
time knowing if any change is
significant okay so first we're gonna
calculate the mean I'm not gonna I've
never done a put talk like this so I
don't think it totally works for me to
be narrating the entire thing I think we
should sort of all work
a little bit independently and then come
back together just to discuss does that
seem like a good format for this okay
I'm just taking that advice for my
friend that you guys are all really
silent when you're happy
okay so what do we all think is this
difference significantly different than
30 no okay our p-value is 0.5 6 that's
too high and just print the mean really
okay yeah so we can see that even though
the mean is indeed higher than 30 our
p-value is insignificant now that
doesn't mean just because it isn't
significant that doesn't mean that it's
not true in this case I think in our in
our scenario here we're monitoring the
ages of users it's possible that we just
haven't gotten enough data yet and that
as we get more and more data then we'll
want to be doing this cool all right so
let's talk about let me make sure that's
actually the next Thank You mr. temple
no keep talking about one sample oh yeah
this is fun I should really remember
what goes on in this since it's my own
thing so this is actually a fun way if
you're ever sort of unsure about how
you're if you're using the correct
statistical test or not I really enjoy
making up sample data and sort of
getting a feel for how the t-test will
actually operate or whatever statistical
tests are using so in this case what
we've done is we've created a thousand
different sample data sets and we want
to look at is how many of them end up
being significantly different so we have
basically just a great big
two-dimensional array where each row is
one of the different samples we
generated all of these just using and P
dot random dot normal so we can run that
here
so you can kind of get an idea from
looking at all of these that sometimes
it's significant and sometimes it's not
and this is really getting at the
definition of what a p-value is so what
does it mean that P is 0.05 it means
that there's a less than 5% chance that
this happened by accident and another
way of thinking of that is if I had a
hundred random samples under the same
conditions five of them would be
significant even if the overall
distributions were the same and that's
going to become very relevant later when
we talk about having more comparing more
than two samples when we get to a nova I
have to do this I really should have
this in the god mode while I'm doing it
yeah so we happen to have one where
exactly half of these were valid which
is interesting okay okay so let's talk
about two-sample t-tests so to sample
just a little bit more complicated than
one sample it's when both of your
datasets are experimental this is one of
the easiest ones to run you just put the
two different distributions in it
shouldn't matter what order you put it
in it shouldn't say T sample one it
shouldn't you say T sample independent
that's annoying or T test and but we
just plug in our two distributions now
this is doing a this is gonna by default
do a two-tailed test does anyone know
the difference between a two-tailed test
versus a one-tailed test anyone want to
raise their hand and tell us yeah you're
the only one who wants to raise your
hand here oh go for it okay okay so what
does that actually mean in practice a so
yeah
yeah so a two-tailed test basically says
I don't care if it's greater than if you
know sample two is greater than or less
than sample one I just want to know if
there's a different a one tailed test is
where we say I know that if they're
different it's because the second sample
is gonna be greater or the sample second
sample is going to be less than and the
reason you would use a one tailed test
is it makes it a little bit easier it
divides your what you need by two so
something that is not significant in a
two-tailed test it can be significant in
a one tailed test and the trick is
knowing which of those is valid so for
instance did you have a really good
reason to believe that it should be one
tailed that if there was going to be a
difference that it would absolutely be a
greater greater than or are you really
just looking for any difference in the
direction doesn't matter okay
so let's give that a try here and it's
still not resetting properly well okay
so in this case we have two two
different vectors representing two
different weeks and about the amount of
time spent on a website so we can really
quickly calculate the mean
okay so looks like they're different
anyone have any ideas about before we
even do hypothesis testing what are some
good ideas to try and decide if two if
the means being different is real or not
what are some things that we might want
to try before we even do a hypothesis
test yeah yep plotting his histograms
two good ways to do that you can plot
them on top of each other in matplotlib
or you can use magical violin plots and
Seabourn does everyone know what a
violin plot is it's really weird-looking
so what it does is you all know what a
histogram is it takes it's really
difficult it's really difficult to
compare two histograms to each other if
you're using matplotlib you've got to
somehow make them like semi-transparent
and then you probably want to normalize
them so that they sort of look the same
and comparing more than two is really a
mess because they're all on top of each
other and it's hard to see so what a
violin plot does is it takes your
histogram it rotates it by 90 degrees
and doubles it because symmetry is
pretty that part I never really got it
doesn't have to do that and then you
sort of have them plotted next to each
other like bars and it makes it really
easy to see if your histograms are
different that's particularly important
to do before doing any of these T tests
because these only work if our data is
quasi normally distributed and we'll go
into detail a little bit later about
what that means because obviously most
data isn't normally distributed right
most data has some sort of skew in it
does everyone know what normally
distributed means does anyone want me to
go over that awesome okay I'm gonna keep
working through this we've decided we're
all gonna work a little bit
independently on this because it's very
boring if I just narrate typing but this
way everyone at least gets to practice
okay so is everyone gotten to the point
of calculating the p-value is it
significant or not is it less than 0.05
or greater than 0.05 I'm again you're
very quiet and I have been told that
means that you love this talk
so our p-values you can see up here is
much less than 0.05 that means that
we're in good shape here any idea if you
all forgot at some point which came
first as the output the t-stat or the
p-value how you could kind of eyeball it
and tell the difference the T stat is
always going to be like a big number
generally it's generally gonna be you
know greater than one or you know
greater absolute value greater than one
your p-value is generally the thing
that's going to be you know hopefully if
not less than 0.05 you know in the
neighborhood of like Oh point two point
three okay so this is where things start
to get fun is talking about the dangers
of multiple t-test I am going to just
sort of go off script and talk for a
while because this is something that I
actually feel very passionately about so
who here has heard of the
reproducibility crisis and bio
biochemistry yeah can you tell us a
little bit about what it is yeah
basically a lot of pharmaceutical so I
used to be in drug development the way
that drug development tends to work is
that the basic research isn't done by
the drug companies it's done by research
labs at universities so the universities
go they try and figure out if
something's true they publish it with P
less than 0.05 and then the
pharmaceutical companies say ok you've
told me that this protein if I can just
find a drug that makes it turn off this
is the right protein to cure diabetes or
to cure Alzheimer's and then they'll go
and
you know try to make a drug court but
more and more the companies have been
trying to reproduce the results that
we're done at universities and found
that it doesn't work now a hint to why
that might be a problem and we'll get to
this a little bit later in the talk is
if you just look at all of the reported
p-values in research and you plot a
histogram of them you'll see the be sort
of a peak right at 0.049 and that's
because people don't publish things that
weren't significant you can't say well I
found out that this particular drug is
like really bad and doesn't do anything
so people tend to keep running their
experiments until they can get to a
point
fi and basically anytime you're running
lots and lots of hypothesis testing you
can start to get into trouble actually
have I'm gonna just skip ahead because I
really like this slide okay does anyone
read xkcd I really hope that many of you
do okay so this is a great cartoon it's
kind of hard to read but it's about
jellybeans so here what we have this is
actually a perfect demonstration of why
we need to use ANOVA so here we're
saying hey you know jellybeans cause
acne scientists go investigate and they
do it for all colors of jellybeans and
they say nope there's no link and they
say well maybe it's only certain colors
so they test every color and you can see
they finally get one result that's less
than 0.05 now if we think about it
yellow was not the best color for this
but there are exactly twenty of these
experiments and one of them had key less
than 0.05 that's exactly what a p-value
tells you right is that 5% one out of
twenty experiments even where there is
no real difference will magically get
this and that's why you want to be
really careful about running lots and
lots of T tests so what's the solution
to that solution is something called a
nova
so a nova is a different distribution
you don't have to worry too much about
what's going on under the hood but it's
something that is going to allow us to
test lots of different the difference
between lots of different data sets
without running into this problem now
what's very confusing is it's not called
anova inside pie it's called f1 way
because the distribution it uses is
called an F distribution as opposed to a
student's key distribution and you'll
notice instead of getting a t stat out
we get an F stat out but it's basically
the same thing so I really should have
gone into god mode I actually have to do
all the work on this now oh no I don't
great okay so we're on I know but we do
a nova and the it's just going to give
us one key value back right so we've
compared all these different
distributions and all it said is you
know yes your p is less than 0.05 but
that doesn't actually tell us which of
the distribution is different and so in
order to do that we're gonna need
another hypothesis test called two keys
which is a funny name so we can take a
moment to laugh at that if we want but
apparently that is not the order that we
teach this in in this class first we
talk about assumptions that we need so
this is cool so we're going back to this
okay so remember when I talked about
podding those violin plots or histograms
and that they're a good idea they're not
just a good idea to get a ballpark of
whether or not there's a significant
they're also really important for our
assumptions and this is like a
particularly big deal with a ANOVA
t-test is a little bit more resilient to
funny data ANOVA you really do need for
your data to be normally distributed ish
and mostly that just means that it's not
bimodal and where this can get really
tricky is if you have a small relatively
small sample set so if you have a big
data set it's very easy to plot the
histogram and be like hey that data is
by not modal but if you're working with
a smaller data set it might not be super
obvious so that's when you have to
really think about what your data is and
say is this something where I reasonably
believe that it should be normally
distributed or is it something where I
can imagine it
by modal so an example we give here is
like traffic times peak traffic times
this is true both of like actual traffic
you know through a stop light but also
traffic to a website when you're doing
a/b testing it's not entirely
unreasonable to think that there might
be two peaks a morning and an evening
peak which would make a nova not work
the population standard deviation should
be equal ish generally the way we test
for that is we just take the ratio and
we're looking for something you know
between point eight and one point two so
that they're sort of close but they
don't have to be on top of each other
the samples must be independent and
independent means knowing something
about one of them shouldn't affect
another one of them so good examples of
this is basically if it's the same
people in the data set so if you know I
know that I'm comparing a before and
after you know this is actually not the
best way to do that okay so I'm gonna
skip ahead to actually get to the thing
that is cooler than a nova and that's
two keys range test so two keys range
test is cool it is not inside pi this is
the only thing I'm gonna teach it's not
in the sci-fi it's actually in stats
models and what's really nice about it
is it tells you exactly which of your
pairs of data set he's the one that's
different so if I just keep pushing run
it'll eventually just give me the answer
oh that's another fun thing if you keep
pushing run enough times it'll just tell
you the right answer no but it won't for
me because I already put in the things
all right
so oh yeah so this is an important part
about how two keys range test works it's
different so because it's stats model
and not Syfy the arguments are a bit
different so instead of you just so
notice how when we did ANOVA which is
cleverly named F one way
put in the three separate data sets and
then we just run it for reasons the way
that two key works is you actually have
to make it into one set of tables data
that one data set with labels so if
you're using pandas this is really easy
if you have you know a column of labels
and then a column of values you're in
really good shape if you're not using
pandas if you just have loaded in three
separate CSVs it's a little bit annoying
because you'll have to create a vector
of labels but once you have that you can
just do a pairwise
and then the final argument you need to
give it is your significance level
because again it's gonna be doing all of
that stuff for you and rather than
giving you back to individual key levels
it's gonna repeat values it's gonna give
you yeses and noes so you have to tell
it what threshold you want to use for
yeses and noes again we generally use
0.05 if it's something that doesn't
matter a whole lot you can use point one
if it's something that really really
matters like you're working on like a
space shuttle and if you screw it up
people are gonna get blown up maybe you
want to use something like point bow one
so you run this and what's really what's
really nice about Tiki is it is by far
the prettiest output that we will get
okay well that was less pretty cool so
yeah so what's really nice here is it
actually just gives you this little
reject thing and what is it talking
about when it says reject it's talking
about the null hypothesis are we
rejecting the null hypothesis I'm saying
that groups are different so here it's
saying a isn't different from C B's and
different from C but a is different from
B this is actually can be a really
interesting thing that you end up with
when we get to the a/b testing part I'm
gonna talk a little bit about kind of a
crazy a B test that I ran because if you
think about it it's kind of weird you
think of like the transitive property in
mathematics right if a isn't
distinguishable from C and B is
indistinguishable from see how can a be
to not be distinguishable from B well
it's cuz they're a little bit further
apart than kind of managed and you've
got a and B and then C so a and C or
further enough apart but B is kind of in
the middle cool okay so now we are
getting into the categorical task so if
we think back to or if we just look back
because we can go back like that now
we're into that categorical column so
that's
a lot of times I think what you're more
likely to see with a be tests you could
do my no meal test you can do if you are
comparing against a known quantity or a
chi-squared test if you're comparing
against if you're comparing multiple
datasets against each other
chi-square is interesting because it
actually will work with more than two
samples it has that correction in it now
there's something else that's called oh
gosh I'm blanking on it yeah Fisher's
exact so if you have very small datasets
chi-squared will have more errors and
you'll want to switch to Fisher's exact
luckily the sigh hi Chi square test
actually has that as one of the keyword
arguments but generally you know most
people don't need to use that most
people can are good with just using
chi-square but first let's talk about
binomial so binomial test we're
comparing against a target value again
you can read this but I'm going to talk
a little bit about while you guys work
through this example I'm gonna talk
about another example where is binomial
test which was sort of interesting which
is in a pricing test so we were
experimenting with microtransactions we
wanted to make certain lessons that
people would have to buy instead of
having them just be available for free
so we were trying to see what if we were
gonna do that what should we price it at
should we press it up 199 or 399 and it
was funny this actually happened on a
day when I was kind of not paying
attention I was kind of busy with other
things so a product manager came to me
and said hey I'm running a chi-squared
test can you please show me how to
calculate it I said oh sure I pulled up
my notes from this I showed him how to
do a chi-squared contingency test and
walked away and then about an hour later
I realized that I didn't trust him I'm
sorry keep acting like hey Bryan
what were you testing he's like oh it
was great I was doing this pricing test
and what do you know more people clicked
on it when it was $1.99 than when it was
399 and as a scientist we should all
facepalm a little bit because of course
more people will click on a cheaper
thing but that's not really what we want
to know we want to know
are you actually getting more overall
money and there's a couple different
ways that you can test this but binomial
can actually work really well for this
so you can say rather than saying like I
want to compare the percentage of people
who clicked you can say something like
well I know it's gonna cost us so much
to build out this feature so I know that
I need some minimum amount of you know
money that I have to make per month so
maybe you say something like I need to
make I'm just gonna use round numbers to
make it easy I need to make a hundred
dollars a month and if you're selling it
for $1.99 well that means that you need
about 50 clicks versus if you're selling
it for $4.99 that means you need about
25 clicks so you can look at your
monthly traffic I can figure out what
those two percentages are and compare
use the binomial test to compare the
actual values against that minimum
amount that you would need to be able to
justify the test and that's actually a
really good use of a binomial so instead
of comparing the two numbers against
themselves you compare them each against
the target and once you're sure of that
then you can start doing things like
just doing regular multiplication obtain
how much profit am I actually getting
from each of these but yeah I think this
is a really good story because it
reminds us that we can know all of these
tests but what matters is you know not
thinking of them as scary math but
thinking of them as common-sense and
things that we have to always be using
our non math brain to think through okay
so here's the actual chi-squared test
and it's called something called Chi 2
contingency it's also imported from sy
PI dot stats it's also slightly
different because you know we have to
make things complicated otherwise it
would get boring
so for chi-squared test we have to
actually build a contingency table and
I'm actually gonna pull up an online
there's a lot of really good online
chi-squared test you don't have to do it
inside
I like to do it because CyHi doesn't you
know go offline but if I look up so this
is a really good one and the reason I
like it is it lets you interactively
build your contingency table and it's
far too small for you to read yeah that
looks reasonable and it makes you really
think about it so with a be testing a
lot of people will do this wrong they'll
say something like total visits you know
and visits and this will be something
like total number of purchases and
they'll be have you no control and
variance this is actually wrong because
the contingency test what it's supposed
to do is take all of the people who
visit your site and divide them into
buckets so the total number of things in
the contingency table should add up to
the total visitors so instead of this
being a funnel where you sort of have
100 percent of people in the first
column and then some percentage in the
second this should actually be a number
who didn't purchase and it would look
something like that
but so yeah I actually find this quite
helpful sometimes instead of using the
SyFy test because it forces you to write
out your thinking in a way that it's
very easy to not do when you're just
making a numpy array but anyway you do
that
this one has four outputs which is super
exciting the second one is the one that
we actually care about
and in this case it wasn't it wasn't
significant and it's not letting me go
on to the next one because we're at the
final exercise excellent cool so now we
get to get to the fun stuff
okay so we've learned a whole bunch of
different statistical tests we also know
when to use them now we want to get into
sort of the so what the bigger
experimental design questions so
generally these are the roughs
the rough steps that we want to go
through when we're doing experiment
where we're doing an experiment and I
think it's really important even if
you're working at a company and doing an
a/b testing you should still be thinking
of this as a scientific experiment so
that means that the first thing you
should do is state your hypothesis what
do you think is happening this is really
important because a lot of times people
go into a/b testing without fully
thinking through what they think is
gonna happen and that determines
everything from what type of hypothesis
test you should use so like that example
where we talked through the pricing test
or when we talked through if you should
use one-tailed or two-tailed it also
determines what the best metric is that
you should actually track picking a
metric is really important so for
instance one thing that we that we did
once is we were anyway we wanted to know
which course we should build out next
for codecademy so we sent a bunch of
emails out to people you know saying hey
we're thinking about offering you know
course X and they would click on a link
and they would go to a page and and it
would tell them a little bit more about
course X that we thought of we were
thinking about and then they could add
their name to a list if they were
interested and some people were sent to
quotes X some people were sent of course
why some people were sent of course Z
etc and the idea being that we could do
this massive comparison and decide which
course was the most likely to get the
most people to sign up for it and what's
interesting there is there's a whole
bunch of different metrics that you
could use you could use
the entire conversion rate from number
of emails sent to number of people who
actually you know at the end said yes I
want to take this you could use percent
of emails opened so did you know the
subject line of we're thinking about
teaching course acts did that make
people sign up we could use from once
they've opened the email to once they
actually said they were purchased
there's a whole bunch of different
things and having a clearly stated
hypothesis lets you decide which of
those you think is important so for us
we decided that the email headings were
all were really testing what we wanted
they were kind of just testing one you
know word because you can't put that
much description and we really wanted to
know that once people have read through
the just the full description the full
syllabus did they decide to convert so
that was a different metric that we used
was also conveniently because that was a
higher percentage it meant that it was
easier to get to significance so in
general the higher your conversion
percentage the easier is to get to
significant so and that's because it's
very hard to tell the difference between
0.01% and point zero one percent when
you have a finite number of samples
because they might both look like zero
people clicking with a small sample size
but if you're trying to compare 20
percent to 25 percent or even 20 percent
to 21 percent that's a lot easier to
observe the difference because you're
going to get more people clicking anyway
so we pick a metric we calculate the
metric for the control group so this is
really important because it means we
need some information going in so for
that example I was talking about we want
to know just ballpark what percentage of
people click emails is it
are we talking 1 percent or 20 percent
turns out it's far less than 1% nobody
likes to open their emails once we know
that metric for the control group then
we wanted to find the smallest
difference that we're able to detect and
the reason that we do that is it lets us
know
how big of a sample size we need so like
I was saying before just because your
results aren't significant that doesn't
mean that you did the test wrong that
might be the correct answer but in order
to know that you've run it long enough
that you've crossed that threshold from
I just don't have enough information to
have enough information to say that both
of these groups are equal you have to be
able to do a good sample size detection
so the smallest difference you want to
be able to detect the way I generally
explain this to product managers is you
know if I told you that you know 1% more
people signed up is it actually worth it
for you to build out this new feature
that you want what is the difference
that actually you would bother telling
your boss about and that's your minimum
detectable difference so let me just
show you another website that lets you
do this calculation this is Optimizely
it's available for free it lets you
calculate sample sizes you start with
this baseline conversion rate so in our
example before that's the number of
people who open their emails and then
you put in a minimum detectable event
effect so this 20% would be 20% greater
than 3% which would be 3.6 percent and
then the amount of statistical
significance and then this just tells
you the ballpark of how long you're
gonna have to run your experiment in
order to get to a point where you think
it's reasonable where where if the
answer is not significant okay that was
a real answer okay so this goes into
that a little bit more more detail like
what do I do if my results aren't
significant does it mean that I'm a
horrible failure as a person that have
done my experiment wrong and I think
you've all been listening the answer is
no that can be totally fine there's some
nuance to what it means exactly it
doesn't just mean there's no difference
it means the difference between those
two things is smaller than some amount
that amount if you're doing this right
is that minimum detectable difference
that you put into the sample size
detector so for instance if
you had an experiment like this and you
had 12,000 samples pulled per variation
and it was insignificant it means that
the difference is gonna be less than
that 20% and hopefully you've chosen
your minimum detectable difference such
that you don't care if the difference is
less than 20% they're essentially the
same to you the really important thing
is it doesn't mean that you need to run
longer it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't you know keep going and in
fact that can really endanger your
experiment because it's not like you
have perfect data that's always
generating the perfect numbers there can
be random variations and you might
momentarily reach a point where there's
significance and then goes away and so
you're actually biasing so when we
talked about the reproducibility crisis
a really common thing that people will
do is say ooh I'm at point zero eight
for my p-value that's really close let
me run another replicate and see if I
can get to 0.05 and they'll run just
until they get to 0.05 and then they'll
stop and although it seems like that's
okay because they've done a significance
test it's actually a problem because
they they're not gonna keep running
after they hit 0.05 and risk it going
back up again so they've actually
created a biased flip of the coin if you
will okay so we finished up a little bit
earlier if people aren't interested in
want to learn more we have a whole line
of courses on these topics we have an
introduction to data analysis which this
course that you just took is part of we
have learned sequel from scratch which
is a really great way to learn sequel
for data analysis and it's very focused
around business cases and business
metrics and then we have data
visualization with Python which focuses
around matplotlib and Seabourn so you
can learn how to make those cool violin
plots that are the histograms turned on
their side look all pretty so what
questions can I answer for you about
statistical significance
okay yes yeah that's a great question
and that's how I used to feel about this
until I made this chart um
I feel like it's really important to be
able to sit down and think about these
different things so sometimes your data
is numerical and you're comparing two
means together so some examples of that
would be I'm comparing blood pressure I
want to see if blood pressure changes
when I apply a medication or I'm
comparing scores on an exam I want to
see if some people score higher on an
exam than other people
those are things where we're in that
numerical category categorical is really
tricky because a lot of people don't
realize that they have categorical data
categorical data is whenever you have a
percent and you're comparing different
percents with each other so examples of
that would be number of people who click
a link to a website even though you're
looking at a number you're really
talking about a percentage and you want
to see if the percentages have changed
between your two different experiments
also this idea that you can be comparing
different numbers of things you can be
comparing against a known target or you
can be comparing two different examples
to each other does that help
yeah um yeah I'm trying to think if
there's anything else I can save it up
yeah so I think it depends I think ANOVA
is actually relatively robust to things
not being normally distributed I think
you really have to look out for is
bimodal data and when you have bimodal
data I think a lot of times you actually
should be saying you know do I really
want to be comparing this whole is this
really one data set or is this two
different data sets and you might
actually want to end up splitting those
out and ending up comparing three things
rather than just comparing a bimodal
data set to a univariate data set yes
that's a really excellent question the
short answer is you can't
the long answer is I think for things
like seasonality you look at the past
years you look and see what those trends
are and you can actually do something
like maybe instead of comparing week one
to week two you compare the difference
between week one a year ago and this
year and week two a year ago and this
year so I did something a little bit
similar to that I wanted to when I was
working at the educational technology
company we didn't have access to like
test results we couldn't test people on
a cumulative exam what we did have his
successive homework assignments and we
wanted to look at you know did people do
better on homework - after having had an
adaptive intervention after homework one
and that was a really interesting case
where you know we would expect some
change between homework 1 and homework 2
is that when we did have a little bit of
an a/b test and that because we did have
some people who hadn't had the
information but still we had to compare
a difference to or rather two sets of
differences rather than comparing two
individual men measurements so I think
yeah I think that that's a good way I
think it's also just really important to
be aware of what's what else is going on
because sometimes you know if you look
at your data over time you might say
actually week 1 and week 2 there
shouldn't be a big difference between
them you know but if you know that like
another person at your company is also
running an experiment that's like a big
problem like you're not gonna be able to
decouple those and then a final option
that you could do is rather than
comparing week 1 to week 2 compare like
weeks you know 1 through 10 to week 11
and you can do something like take a
whole bunch of data you can either like
do a Nova's and compare all or do to key
in there
all of them or you can do something like
say I have so much data from week 1
through 10 that I'm no longer doing a
two sample test I'm going to consider
week 1 through 10 to be a known quantity
and do the the sample versus known
quantity yes
yeah this is also another good example
this is like fake data but if you can do
more than week 1 and week 2 if you can
have a bunch of data points before and a
bunch of data point after that works
quite well we do that fairly frequently
because sometime like pricing is
actually a really good example where a
lot of times you just can't do an a/b
test because they'll be leakage between
the two groups and people know the other
thing that's just good to know generally
for if it's specifically a/b testing on
like a website there are more and more
tools available so that your engine you
don't have to ask your engineers to
build two versions of something like I
think it's Google optimized you can tell
it to go in and edit HTML for you and
actually like it sits on top of your
website and like you can we actually did
use it for pricing tests which is a
little bit of a weird example but like
we actually edited the bit that said you
know it costs this many dollars to
something else yes that's a good
question I don't know because code
Academy doesn't have an app yet but
we're working on it
but I feel like there's got to be you
know especially like if if your app is
like built-in react or something like
that that's not so different from you
know the regular Internet but if it's
like an iOS app it would have to be
something more specialized fun but yeah
I don't think it's necessarily bad to
compare week 1 to week 2 as long as you
fully understand what's going on and
that there isn't something else big that
happened that you're not for instance
comparing a random week in July to the
week before Christmas I think it's very
another thing that we've started doing
just generally to make sure that we're
not stepping on each other's toes is
make sure that we have a running
document of what experiments are being
run and we're pretty strict about
telling people like you if something is
not an a/b test if it's a week over week
we'll stop we'll keep other people we'll
have a free
it's on releases for those two weeks and
say you can't do anything because we're
really trying to measure this one
quantity other questions yeah yeah
that's an interesting question um it
depends on what information you have
going in so if you so if you've buried
something before so for instance you
know if you know that this so I'm trying
to think of a good example of this you
know if you know that you've had
different prices at different points in
time or something I'm stuck on pricing
test because that's what I'm thinking
about but I think a better example would
be if you have something like if you're
in economics and you have a lot of
natural experiments happening
so for instance if you you know I don't
know if you're looking at sales on rainy
versus clear days and you know you've
had it before you can probably do
something like PCA to get like a
dimension that has the maximal variation
but I think in a lot of cases the reason
you're running a test is because you
don't have data on it and then what I
think is really important is spending a
lot of time talking to you know if it's
a UX designer that's making a change if
it's a product managers making a change
and really understanding what you
believe you're doing so for instance a
conversation I've had actually so this
was a thing that happened a lot a lot of
people pick metrics that are way too
macro so they'll say some it ok ours or
a thing here in England right I'm not
crazy when I'm saying ok are good ok so
like you know I I think of every ok our
is basically a little mini X
merriment and people will say things
like well I want the kr for my you know
small engineering team to be money made
by the entire company and say like
that's bad because so many things are
going to affect that and so I try to
when we're doing quarterly planning I
scheduled meetings with every product
manager and really try to drill in on
you know okay what is it that you think
you're doing oh you think that you're
you know you're gonna be sending alerts
to people telling them that it's been so
many days since they've been on the
platform and your hypothesis really is
that you're going to increase engagement
and even more than that you're going to
decrease the number of people with more
than X days of inactivity and so trying
to get it something really really
specific that actually tests the thing
you're changing and I think that is a
better practice for a like it's funny
that this is actually a thing also in
biology it's called like the difference
between it's been a long time since I
did biology but like for instance you
can test you know how a drug binds
specifically to a molecule or you can
test the overall effectiveness of you
know whatever the process is and you can
do the same thing in you know
engineering a website you can either
test the actual thing that you're think
you're doing versus testing that the
thing you think you're doing actually
affects the bottom line and I think it's
important to sort of do both but a lot
of times you can't get at that overall
did we make more money because of this
without first establishing that the
thing happened if that makes any sense
other questions
this is way more fun than like doing
math on the website yep yeah no because
I can't convince anyone to build a
system so that I can do like multi-armed
bandit but I've seen people do that it's
really cool it's much more on the sort
of engineering side of things of getting
them to build so does anyone know what
we're talking about is anyone heard of
like Bayesian approaches to to survey
design or to Sam to experimental design
so there's this concept called
multi-armed bandit and I am led to
believe that the reason for that the
like situation that it's based on is you
walk into a casino with those slot
machines where you like pull the arm and
apparently they were called bandits and
you think that one of them is like
better than the others and you want to
optimize between exploration so trying
all of the machines and exploitation
spending the most time on the machine
that is the best and this is actually
very relevant to a/b testing it's also
relevant to like you know you can think
of lots of situations where the goal is
to get to the best thing as quickly as
possible and so there are I took out my
sights on Bayesian statistics that makes
me release hat but there are methods
where you basically start by saying you
know overall this is my expectation of
how it works I'm gonna start by equally
pulling on all of the arms or equally
testing each thing and then as one
starts to look a little bit better
I'll start driving more of my traffic to
the better one and not only is this good
it's really good when you have lots of
options and not only is it good because
it's maximizing whatever the good thing
is but it's also good because it takes
fewer samples to prove that things that
are really different are different from
each other
super instance if one of those slot
machines was just
terrible and never paid out you can
prove that very quickly but it takes
many more samples to prove that two
things that are close to each other are
different and so you're driving all your
traffic that way again there are a lot
of platforms that will do this for you
because the bigger challenge like it the
math isn't super hard like you can
google it it's much harder to build the
actual engineering system and convince
your engineers that it's a good idea
does everyone know what Bayesian is
because there's a really good xkcd
cartoon if anyone wants me to explain it
yep okay cool it's a really good okay so
okay so this is my favourite way of
explaining yes so super funny cartoon so
they've got a little machine here and
it's going to tell us if the Sun
exploded or not and it's going to take a
measurement and then before it tells us
the result of the measurement it's gonna
roll two dice and if it happens to roll
two sixes it will lie to us
so in this case it you know rolls the
dice and it says yes the Sun is exploded
and the frequentist statistician says
well it's pretty unlikely to roll two
sixes that's P less than 0.05 therefore
you have the Sun exploded where is the
Bayesian statistic the statistician says
that you're 50 bucks it hasn't so even
if you don't know Bayesian statistics
you get this joke inherently right
what is the Bayesian statistician
thinking that it's like quite unlikely
that the Sun exploded right so that
extra piece of information knowing that
the Sun exploding is very unlikely
that's called a prior and Bayesian
statistics is all about incorporating a
prior and then up and then using new
information to update the prior so the
other classic example of this is disease
detection so for instance if you have a
if you're a doctor and you have a
patient come in and you're testing them
for a very rare disease and you're
testing them for a disease that only
occurs in one out of a hundred thousand
and you have a very accurate test the
test is correct 99% at the time and you
test the person it comes back positive
you would think that means they have the
rare disease but what Bayesian
statistical this actually says as well
the test is wrong one out of a hundred
times the disease occurs one out of a
hundred thousand times
therefore it's actually much more likely
for the test to be wrong than it is that
the person has the disease so it
actually tells you that you should
perform the test until the error gets
lower than the rate in the population
and then you'll be able to say like okay
now I have enough information when I
worked at the adaptive learning company
they actually also used Bayesian
statistics in kind of a cool way so
another intuitive thing if I have two
students and I'm asking the maths
questions and I ask one student one
question and he gets it right and asked
another student ten questions and she
gets nine of them ranked we know
inherently there's some reason I trust
that nine out of ten student much more
like I'm much more confident that she
knows the material than the one out of
one student even though a hundred
percent is greater than ninety percent
so you can actually use Bayesian
statistics to figure out what somebody
knows but you start with the prior of
you know I assume that you know there's
a 50/50 chance that they get the
questions right or if it's multiple
choice you'd say something like I assume
there's a 25% chance one out of four
that they get the question right and
then you update it as they go did anyone
here take the GRE for grad school okay
it's an online it's an online or it's a
test that you tape it to get into grad
school but it's computerized and people
really hate it because it has a Bayesian
model and it will actually as you proof
as you know as you get questions correct
or incorrect it'll start upping or lower
in the level of each question to make it
harder or easier that was a fun little
divergence if you had their questions
okay I think we're good um thank you all
for coming and thank you all for
wrapping up a little bit early and just
one more time because my bosses will be
very sad if I don't do this three
different boot camps available for for
199 dollars which is even less in pounds
there are between six and ten weeks
require about ten hours per week of work
and they're fun because I wrote them and
you guys have all had fun here
[Applause]